I'm delighted to welcome to today's
panel on i'ma go gets excellent
terror in Chechnya
now Princeton University I'm delighted
that you joined us for this what should
be an interesting discussion not only
about there but also some of I think the
themes that the book brings up in terms
of Chechnya we have a very distinguished
panel both policymakers and academics in
the spirit of the seminar series that
Jack's might or not our code directly on
human right strategies and now comes a
part of the intent is debris dialogue
between the two communities on actual
how effective certain strategies are
what are the policy locations legal
implications and so forth so this fits
really well and thank you to Laura or
organizing everything and really having
the idea to do this as part of this
series were we're very grateful so but
today's panel is comprised of four
members and Gilligan after is after
completing her doctoral studies in
Washington history at the University of
Melbourne she was a postdoctoral fellow
in the Department of history at the
University of Chicago now she is it's
not here but by the University of
Connecticut she is the author of two
important books the first ravaged 2004
defending human rights in Russia Sergey
Cavalli a participant and Human Rights
commissioner's 1969 96 and her second
book terror in Chechnya
they Russia the tragedy the civilians in
the water
Princeton University Press 2000 Anya so
the book examines the war crimes
committed by Russian soldiers against
the civilian population of Chechnya in
the study places the conflict in Chechen
within international discourse on
humanitarian and erection 1990s the rise
of nationalism in Russia emma has also
contributed op-ed and policy articles in
place like Chicago review an
International Herald Tribune and she's a
member of blackstein's American human
rights Android hired Human Rights
Institute welcome Kim Martin is my
colleague at Barnard College and
distinguished professor of political
science she's also a faculty member of
Aryan Institute a light member of the
Council on Foreign Relations she has
written three books all on various
cutting edge topics in international
security enforcing the peace lengthen
imperial past weapons culture and
self-interest Soviet defense managers in
Russia
follow me mr. president human seven and
engage in the enemy organization theory
Soviet military innovation president
worst ahead with a degree for which he
received the acclaim Marshall Coleman
prize maranatha prepared a number of
scholarly journals and also she's
hanging in number of policy pieces and
she's also conducted two open source
project projects director of net
assessment the Pentagon so she has an
academic integrity policy world and she
has just finished a great new book
forthcoming from Cornell University
Press at some point early I'm not
warlords estates she includes a chapter
on Montford era of Chechnya so in were
grateful to have your air warlordism
Jason Lisle PhD Cornell University
currently assistant professor of
political science at Yale University's
most director of undergraduate studies
and he's affiliated with institutional
social policy studies area studies he's
working currently on three projects what
else have you done he's like we was
interesting minds in the field even at
his sort of young age always attends how
state violence affects public attitudes
in the circuit violence in Afghanistan
Iraq versus North Caucasus he's
published and all sorts of great places
into the International Organization
chiral conflict resolution and he's won
many different crises so oh and of
course
Jason's flagship publication far has
been a piece about Chechnya and
insurgency in the American Political
Science Review which is rare enough or I
are still welcome Jason and finally last
but not least give that woman is a
senior researcher with the Health and
Human Rights Division acting in the
Rights Watch who leads the
organization's research and advocacy on
fellowship care and pain treatment his
work has exposed mass suffering from
severe but unnecessary pain by patients
more work with cancer HIV and other
health conditions because many times
they'll make it expensive safe and
effective medications
mr. Logan is conducting the supervising
research in India Kenya you
southern countries in spirit spearheaded
advocacy commission on narcotic some
drugs they are National Archives Control
Board the World Health Organization but
other institutions to address these
issues and he's also worked with the
year from 1997 2006 and Central Asia
division Human Rights Watch first with
Moscow office director in 1997 2002 then
as senior researcher for Russian Ukraine
and Belarus
so in those capacities he exposed
systematic torture police presence in
Russia and in Russian army and the
covered abuses committed in the armed
convoy judge Nina I cannot think of for
more qualified individuals to take on
this path I've gone on long enough
I will ask Emma to begin with a
presentation about 15 minutes on the
main findings points in her book then
all I asked him Jason and Deirdre
connect order at their 12 minutes
engaging with Emma's book and many other
Harmonized that they want to hold over
the basin comments for each other
give me without the microphone is that
okay yeah okay great
well I might take ten minutes and then
five minutes for my defense after the
street people have given their synopsis
of my work in beds all right um thanks
again to the Harriman Institute and to
Lara and your colleagues for organizing
this it's nice to be here
I must say that I wish in a way that
you'd organize this when my book
manuscript was still in draft form and I
could have got your feedback then but
nevertheless say I'm looking forward to
hearing your comments today I realized
actually that colleagues here are going
to talk about the text of the book and I
look forward to hearing and being able
to discuss that so what I thought I'd do
with my little time is to talk to you a
little bit about what my aim and my
purpose was with writing this book and
just to give you some context about
where I was coming
so I have to admit that my initial aims
are very modest I wasn't really trying
to create any new intellectual territory
I wasn't trying to come up with any new
necessary philosophies or political
ideas what I was trying to do was to
bring together the information that was
available at a particular moment in
historical time into a compact setting
in which undergraduates and those
interested readers could actually open
up a book and find out about one
dimension of the crisis in church now I
know that other scholars such as a
Matthew evangelist ER and John Dunlop
and James Hughes have done a great deal
of work of looking at the political side
of this conflict and trying to
understand the cause of origins of that
of the conflict itself so I felt having
I was living in Russia twice both during
the first war between 1992 or actually
sorry 1994 and 1996 and then I was there
again from 1994 to 2002 so I seem to be
living inside the country at to very
extreme moments and I think that part of
the motivation was seeing the difference
within the reaction of the Russian
public to the second war as opposed to
the first war and this struck me as
quite extreme and I was curious to try
and understand some of the motivations
behind that change so essentially I
wanted to put everything together so
people had access to try and understand
exactly what we know about the crisis I
wanted to make very clear that as
Diedrich well knows that with access to
only 30 percent of the territory there's
so much that we don't know and so I
wanted to make a couple of proposals or
things that I wanted people to talk
about this was what do we do
asymmetrical Wars when you actually
don't have access to information so my
plea initially when I was at the
University of Chicago was for a large
documentation project and I know
obviously that memorial and the Russian
Chechen Friendship Society have also
been working on that but I think that
there is a need to to actually promote
that further so I wanted to open up that
discussion about the fact that has that
victims really are always at a
historical disadvantage right so how do
we regenerate a discussion of the
victims and to me the only way to do
that is actually to as much as possible
document what's happened to them so I at
UConn now where I am in the Human Rights
Institute we're actually starting a
pilot project with some of the refugees
in their 16000 Chechen refugees living
in Austria so we're starting a pilot
project there to try and gather people
to talk about their experiences and
we're also hoping to start up a website
where people can actually also put their
experiences online this is very
experimental it's problematic on a
number of levels that we're all very
aware of but it's a way for us to I
guess try and generate more information
for for our purposes as much as for the
purposes of enlightening people as to
what has taken place so I think that's
essentially what all I wanted to say I
just wanted to outline what what my aims
were and I think that bringing forth the
discussion about documentation bringing
forth a discussion about okay how do we
categorize exactly what's taking place
in Russia and can we do that without
having all the documentation that we
need at hand to make claims about how we
categorize this by the concern by
international law for example so I did
want to also open up that discussion the
last and final thing that I want to say
is that I was very interested in the
idea of public hearings or the
idea of non government tribunals
particularly in cases like this where
there is no international funding where
there are no Truth and Reconciliation
commissions and so there isn't the
support there for people to come out and
be able to testify about things that
have happened to them so they were may
Ames
I think briefly and so then I'll allow
the others to to talk about their
impressions and also then I perhaps have
an opportunity to respond to that thank
you
well I'm a Gilligan has succeeded
brilliantly this is a very powerful book
she provides a really detailed history
of the true horror of Russian behavior
in Chechnya and I think it's a
definitive account that includes lots of
examples that aren't found elsewhere I
think she also is very correct in
dismissing the United States and United
Nations reaction to what was happening
in Chechnya as being focused on other
political and security motives and
largely ignoring the plight of the
Chechen people and she usefully points
out that this started under President
Bill Clinton it was not just an artifact
of the war terror I think that she's
also correct in calling out the Russian
government for its failure to follow the
Geneva Conventions she makes it very
clear that Russia committed terrible war
crimes and also committed crimes against
humanity sometimes during the era of the
Putin presidency in particular I was on
panels with Russian scholars and anytime
that the Russians were criticized for
what they were doing in Chechnya the
answer would always be oh you have no
right to criticize us because the United
States is doing the same thing in Iraq
or the United States is doing the same
thing in Afghanistan and I think this
book makes clear that what was happening
in Chechnya was not just individual
soldiers who committed torture or murder
in Chechnya it was not just state errors
in judgment about targeting that
happened in Chechnya it actually was
state policy to target Chechen civilians
for brutal attack and that didn't start
under Putin but it continued under Putin
and so I think you know the book makes
clear that the Russian state especially
under the Putin
presidency really had no real concern
about human rights questions and for all
of those reasons the book is incredibly
powerful and incredibly valuable that
haven't been said there are two parts of
the book that I take issue with and both
of the parts that I take issue is come
from the work that I have done looking
at the Chechnya case as Alex mentioned
in the book that has not yet been
accepted by Cornell even though it's
submitted there and under consideration
and so in the book which is about
warlords and sovereignty I talked about
Ramzan Kadyrov who is the current leader
of the Chechen Republic who was
appointed to that position by Vladimir
Putin so the two parts of the book that
I take issue with the first is that I
don't think that Emma Gilligan has a
sufficiently nuanced discussion of the
motives of Chechen fighters she's
careful to be balanced she talks about
war crimes and crimes against humanity
that were conduct were committed by
Chechen fighters against the russian
population as well as what russian
people did to the Chechens but i think
she's very quick to label the motive of
chechen violence as being revenge for
russian atrocities and even though she
does a very good job of documenting the
different times that Chechen fighters
targeted Russians I think maybe she's a
little bit too quick to forgive the
Chechens for the acts of violence that
they committed and I'm sure that revenge
is a big part of what the Chechen
fighters were doing but in the book the
real only alternative that she considers
- revenge is Islamism and religious
belief and the literature on the causes
of rebellion and the causes of political
violence has a vast range of motives
that have been detailed and studied by
scholars both revenge and ideological or
religious belief are important but so is
political economy by political economy
these scholars mean just the desire by
particular individuals or particular
groups to have control over resources
and control over pieces of territory and
it's important to keep in mind that the
Chechen Wars were not simply about the
Russians versus the Chechens
many chechen militias formed before the
russian invasion happened in the sense
that they grew out of organized crime
groups russian militias fought each
other for control over territory and
resources as well as fighting against
the russians and so violence inside
chechnya in a sense predated this most
recent number of russian attacks on
chechnya and we can't look at the whole
situation as just being a black and
white russian vs chechen situation and i
think that that one of the things that's
important to keep in mind when we're
looking at this is that there were all
kinds of violent rivalries between
Ramzan Kadyrov and various militias that
fought against him during the chechen
wars for control over territory and the
particular one that has gotten the most
attention is his fighting with the
Ahmadiyya family B Amadeus had started
out in an alliance with the kadhi ROVs
but they became competitors for
political control and there were
killings of two brothers who the Gama
daya family in 2008 in Moscow in 2009
and Dubai there was an attempted killing
of a third in Moscow in 2009 that was
thwarted by the Moscow authorities and
we don't know for sure that could Arabs
people we're responsible for this but
there's pretty good evidence that
probably it was indeed a result of the
rivalries so one thing to keep in mind
is that this is often reported as blood
feuds and certainly there are blood
feuds that are a part of the Chechen
culture but calling everything a blood
feud is also a way for Ramzan Kadyrov
not to take responsibility for his own
role in violence that occurs and so I
think we need to take the claims of
blood feuds with a grain of salt so just
because the Chechen ships civilians are
victims which I think I'm a Gilligan
does a really good job of describing it
doesn't mean that individuals among them
and significant individuals among them
we're not also perpetrators so the label
of civilian does not necessarily connote
innocence and I think that's an
important thing to keep in mind when
reading Emma Gilligan's book the second
problem that I have with the book is
that I think that the book overreaches
when it claims that the Russian state
pursued genocide
in Chechnya i'ma Gilligan says um you
have a discussion of genocide
significantly throughout the first
chapter but I don't say that it's
genocide okay I misinterpreted at that
yeah I apologize
um but what I want to talk about even
though she didn't say that it was
genocide is that the important thing to
keep in mind is that in going along with
the idea that the violence includes
Chechen on Chechen violence and not just
Russian versus Chechen violence is that
Putin selected the people who are now
ruling Chechnya and happened since 2003
and much of the horrible brutality
against the Chechens is continuing even
though you can make a good argument and
I do in my book chapter that the Russian
state has essentially lost control over
what's happening in Chechnya in
essentially what happened is that Putin
created a warlord in Chechnya the first
person that he appointed to be the head
of chacha Chechnya was named Ahmed
Khedira he was somebody who was
extraordinarily controversial at home in
Chechnya had almost no legitimate
political authority among Chechens and
then when he died in an attack he was
replaced by his son Ramzan who had no
political experience and you can trace
out very clearly how Putin selected
Ramzan in contrast to several other
possible contenders and really ensured
including through campaigns of violence
that runs on himself conducted or appear
to conduct that there would be nobody
else who would be a rival for Rama sons
control and what this means is that
starting in about 2005 and being
finalized in 2009 and 2010 Russia
effectively gave up sovereignty in
Chechnya gradually they granted Khedira
and his militia the legal right to
control security operations and policing
on the territory with almost no Russian
oversight at this point because Ramzan
and his militia have operational control
over what's happening so for example
recently we've heard a lot about laws
have been passed in Chechnya that have
to deal with women's issues and family
issues for example women having to wear
headscarves or women not being allowed
to divorce their husbands and having to
be obedient to their husbands and these
laws don't reflect the laws that are in
place in the rest of Russia but the
Russians are not the Russians the non
Chechen Russians are not the people who
are responsible for enforcing these laws
it's Ramzan Kadyrov's militia that does
the enforcing so you can make the
argument that on the one hand Russia did
this for rational reasons because Ramzan
Kadyrov has done a very good job of
turning people who were against the
Russian state in terms of the drive for
autonomy in Chechnya often he has done
this through threats of violence or
through acts of violence and torture
against the people that he wanted to
turn towards his side but as sergei
Maradona points out Ramzan Kadyrov has
not succeeded in eliminating the threat
of terrorism that emanates from the
North Caucasus and you can make a very
good argument that what Khedira did was
essentially just push the terrorists off
of Chechen territory onto the territory
of other places in the North Caucasus
and so it's not clear that Russia got a
very good bargain for what it did with
Ramzan Kadyrov and what it really
indicates is that Russia chose to wash
its hands of responsibility for what
happened in Chechnya conceptually that's
not so different from the choices that
the u.s. might have made in Iraq and
that NATO has made in Afghanistan the
levels of horrific violence and maybe
not the same quite the same in those two
cases currently as what we've seen in
Chechnya but it's still the same
situation of an outside power
effectively deciding that it didn't want
to spend their resources to manage a
territory and therefore selecting people
on the ground that it felt comfortable
working with to have control over
security situations in selected regions
in its place but the one thing that
really stands apart from the Russian
Chechen example is that Chechnya is
unrushed
territory this was not an outside power
practicing indirect control over a piece
of territory it was Russia practice
endure indirect control on a piece of
its own territory and I think that in in
many senses that makes the the Chechen
situation unique and it says something
important about Russia today as well
sometimes there's a tendency to see
Putin's rule as being evidence that
Russia is once again a strong state that
Russia has regained its sense of
strength after the close of the Cold War
and I think the example of Chechnya and
the outsourcing of sovereignty in
Chechnya indicates that in fact Russia
is terribly terribly weak it did not
have the resources it did not have the
political will to maintain legal control
over the security forces on a piece of
its own territory and in return for
giving up that control it really has not
gotten much in terms of making itself
more secure as the damage yet of a
bombing of January makes clear so I'll
stop there it's already starting up here
I think it's a sign of a great book when
you have lots and lots of questions and
I'm gonna throw more on the table here I
think you succeeded brilliantly I agree
with cam that this is fantastic one of
the problems of studying this conflict
is that not all the materials in one
place and a lot of us actually not in
English and I think that's a huge
service just to put this all in one
place if we can actually get a sense of
what the picture actually looks like in
this conflict and that's what most of
the frustrating things as a teacher
somebody who actually works in the
region as well to send my students
somewhere it's very very difficult there
actually isn't the text that we can send
them to and until now and I think so
this is gonna be a great resource for
people who want to actually springboard
into doing their own research as well I
think that it and when you set up your
goals I think I agree with Kim succeeded
brilliantly but this is no fun if we
just say how good you are right so so
let me let me raise some issues and and
some questions coming out of my own
research and and the 10 second verse of
my own research is that I've spent
considerable Mountain time in Russia
from 2000-2005 working in and around the
Caucasus particularly looking at the
patterns of violence in the Caucasus
both by the Russian side as well as by
the Chechen desertion side my time in
Russia has come to an abrupt end because
I was thrown out of the country for
work than I did but now it looks like
I've had sat out in the corner for about
five years and now I'm good I'm allowed
to go back in so hopefully you're
finishing your book hopefully I'm
allowed to go back in this summer and
start up again so so this for me is
exciting because I get to get back into
the game in some ways and so let me let
me just raise three questions or think
and push you on sort of three issues
once on the state one's on the rebel and
one's on the people themselves and by
the people I mean the Russians who are
watching the conflict go on as well as
the Chechens with in Chechnya as well
and on the first on what the Russians
are doing the book is it is amazingly
detailed on the sort of nitty-gritty of
what actually is going on but I could I
kept waiting for you to step back and
put the pieces together for me what I
wanted to hear was actually your
argument about what was going on and in
some ways you you step back and let the
facts speak for themselves and as much
as we know anyway and you're right 20 30
% of Chechnya we know quite well and the
rest is kind of up in the air but but I
kept trying to figure out what is your
argument for explaining not only the
origins of the conflict but the way in
which it was fun so why is it this
brutal like what was the reason behind
this it didn't have to be necessarily
right so so why did it unfold in a way
that it did and the my best gifts on
your answer actually comes to where you
believe that nationalism and anat racism
or sort of radical notions of race on
the Russian side really drove the
dynamics of the conflict and I think I
think I take that as your thesis and
dattara what worries me about that is
that the racism and the nationalism is
not a cause of the conflict as a
consequence of it so it is actually
being driven right to getting this
progressive nationalist rhetoric is
progressively brutalizing activities on
the ground
not because of some freestanding Russian
hatred of Chechens ethnically or maybe
their yeah historically right there's a
two hundred year legacy but it also is
being fueled by the conflict itself in
some ways I think you have this easy
case to make where you sort of say well
there's a 200 year of history and this
is just round six or seven or eight or
nine of 200 you're counting on the right
I'm actually not but I think that's too
easy right because I think what you need
to be able to do is demonstrate where
the racism is playing a role relative
the areas in which it's not and so I
started looking around and saying there
are some odd puzzles in here if your
story about nationalism
racism art is correct there are some
things I think we shouldn't see in the
conflict that we actually do so let me
raise to two points here one is it
strikes me as odd to see the variation
in the location and the intensity the
route allottee inflicted on the people
if this is a story about Russian racism
or Russian nationalism why is there
variation in how the people are being
treated and let me just show you this is
something from what I'm partly from my
own work here of course it's Windows is
updating itself well if you please see
it thanks let me try that one more time
so just very simply this this is some of
the same data that you're using in your
book followed by memorials internal
record some of the human rights activist
things who are people who are keeping
documentary record of the activities of
the Russians and these are these are the
locations of the sweep operations in
that middle third of Chechnya or over
2000 of 2005 there was a 680 of them
well the one thing to note is actually
the spatial variation in some places are
absolutely ransacked forty times thirty
times right some places get swept once
and that's about it twice three times
that's the smaller dots in here right
some places never are swept at all in
this conflict and so for somebody to say
well it's racism it's nationalism that
to me says why am I seeing this why
isn't all of Chechnya sacked why do I
observe this variation on the behavior
of the Russians soldiers themselves and
you actually in the conclusion point out
that the contract soldiers behaved
differently than the conscript soldiers
did and so now there's a little bit of
nuance in the story about what is this
rush and racism but but I don't know
where that I mean we can imagine where
that comes from
but why is it operative in some places
not others wait why does it seem to
drive the conflict in some places but
again and not in others and so I think
I'm just for me I'm skeptical of these
really big cultural factors that don't
really move right there's just Russian
racism and perhaps Chechen racism in
return but there's all this kind of
variation in the location
the intensity of the violence to me then
the racism is not really driving this it
might actually be coming back out of the
conflict but it seems to me that the
burden of proof if you're going to make
that claim is actually on you to tell us
how is it that it can simultaneously
explain the conflict explain the
patterns explain the variation in the
observed violence and so to me that's
just too far of a reach I think for the
racism the nationalism car but maybe
you've got you know a nuanced
explanation you can get back and that's
maybe in your five minutes but on the
Russian side there's a lot of variation
that I think's not really explained the
other thing is is from that point of
view it strikes me as incredibly odd
that Chechens would leave the rebellion
or the various insurgent groups and join
the Russian side if this is a conflict
about race and ethnicity and nationalism
why is it that there are so many rebels
breaking ranks and joining the Russian
side in fact really 2003-2004 when these
units are stood up at east-west and then
you finally at north and south these
battalions and as well as Ramzan Zone
forces as well why are you getting this
massive defection of the insurgency why
are they defecting to what you would
imagine as there are racial enemies and
in fact to the point where in 2004-2005
right the number of Chechens who were
actually fighting against Chechen rebels
vastly outnumbers in the world of rebels
by 2005 the numbers I mean these you
know the estimates are soft but the
numbers are about a thousand five
hundred fighters still left right at
some points in the height and the
pro-russian Chechen militias up to
20,000 soldiers and so this strikes me
as that he had just bleed out of the
insurgency what is it is it really about
race is it really but nationalist why
aren't the rebels basically looking at
the check of the Russians are saying
they're giving us no mercy they're
giving us no Porter there are racial
enemies we've been doing this for 200
years
there is no quarter we can't go across
we can't cross lines but they do and
they do it in droves
sometimes they surrender on Moss so that
strikes me is there something else going
on in the conflict that's not really
about the race card it's really not
about the nationalism car and I think
actually does work in picked up on the
genocide so I picked up on that too and
I didn't think that you were necessarily
claiming that it was a genocide but I
think you were you were definitely
making the argument that the tomorrow
was ethnic in nature we okay we couldn't
prove that but there's a lot of examples
in here where you're trying to I think
you see this I think you're walking I
think you're walking right up to that
line and looking over it and saying well
I'm not gonna call there's a lot of
things that are so you do need to be
able to prove that intent right does but
I but I think I'm with Kim on this one
you there are suggestive pieces of
evidence yeah you use that basically Len
created you but you're careful right you
say that we don't have all the documents
we're never gonna have all the
documentation right and so I think you
walked right up to that line and don't
but as part of the argument you're
making is driven by its sort of broader
points that certain bi-racial the
notions right racial prejudice and
nationalism and my argument is that
there are other alternative explanations
at work that that these factors have to
be proven and against other social
science theories about what's driving
these conflicts including revenge
including operating motives of the
russian soldiers including theft and
corruption all these other reasons for
the why the violence is the way it is
and so so now I think I've used my 10
minutes on my one point so I'll go a
little faster on the other ones the
second point is the rebels for me are
still a bit of mystery in the book and I
do think that this is very much
documenting Russian crimes there is one
chapter on the on the rebels I agree
with Kim I you know I think there is the
political economy side as of is missing
a bit but actually
it's actually harder just to get a sense
of who the rebels are in the book and I
have partly because this is not your
fault partly because there isn't an
insurgency there are multiple insurgents
right and they sometimes fight with one
another they very different motives and
assertions and so where I where I sort
of push hard on what you're doing is I
don't think this radicalization
narrative the insurgents becoming
progressively Islamic actually holds and
so there is a wing of the insurgent see
that it has become progressively
radicalized no question but there's a
huge schism inside the movement even
today between some more nationalist
forces and more radical groups and they
struggle for dominance of the movement
and the thing that I that I mean that
it's just a sort of commonly repeated
idea right that the movement is become
progressive Islam and progressive
radicalized yet if you look at the
suicide bombings all right that actually
go down the heyday of suicide bombing in
Chechnya is 2001 2002 after that is a
steady decline in the use of these
tactics in fact there's a huge movement
inside the overall movement it's
actually sort of ban these the use of
this it's a it's not working it's it's
alienating the people and so if you look
at the number of suicide attacks inside
Chechnya over time the height is 2002 so
in has been progressively dropping which
is a weird argument behaviorally for
these sort of notions of radicalization
right there have been these in terrorist
groups and terrorist attacks outside of
Chechnya and we've seen who looted some
we've seen number of them it's not clear
that those are Chechens first of all
because the conflict has spread out and
it's second of all it's maybe it's a
single piece of the insurgency but it's
not the whole insurgency and I think we
lose sight of the fact that this
movement is fractured it's divided and I
think oftentimes it's just isn't a
movement sometimes it is just simple
revenge people taking shots at Russian
forces are now Pro Russian and Chechen
forces and it isn't they're not ascribed
to any kind of movement they're just
taking revenge for something that's been
afflicted on them there are estimates
that you know up to 80 percent of the
Taliban in Afghanistan operate in the
same way where we say the Taliban but
isn't there isn't a Taliban and in fact
it may not even be a unified movement I
think this is very much the case in
position yet in part because a Russian
state has shattered the insurgency I
mean I think part of what gets lost a
little bit in
Woori details of the book and and of the
conflict is that the Russians have
largely won in Chechnya and I think this
raises a really interesting set of
questions both morally as well as
pragmatically you know what happens if
you're a human rights activist who wants
to decry these human rights abuses and
the Russian state turns you and said
look we're winning right what is the
what is the push back to go sort of this
theme of the human rights on this panel
and this is speaking seriously what is
the leverage you can use if that state
believes that this is the way in which
it wins and is willing to sacrifice its
own citizens to do this I'm not clear
what the arguments are but if you look
at these practices that the insurgency
has been largely circumscribed to a tiny
corner of Chechnya now and has been
largely marginalized and partly that is
it's a sheer Russian use of brutality in
force not all right there you know part
of it has been the pro-russian Chechen
movement part of it has been dumping of
massive amounts of reconstruction funds
in which is fed corruption but it's
allowed to buy off the rebels so there
is a soft power argument which is not
really in here and the rebels are
injured well the claim the rebels the
the pro-russian government in Chechnya
has largely used force selectively but a
lot of carrots - and this kind of
nuanced perspective I think gets lost we
code them as warlords they think Kim's
right on this but there's been no
actually a lot of strategies not just
that Ramzan is this brutal act or the
tiger there's that side of him but
there's also not clear and we can debate
that in the discussion okay yeah and so
I think there actually is a calculated
strategy oxidant disagree I think
there's Putin has more control than I
think we give them credit for the
situation but we're not gonna talk about
that cuz you and I you're not talking
you and I are not talking either we're
just we're talking here so one minute
yeah the last just very quickly the one
group of people I was really surprised
we're not in the book with Russians
themselves and I wonder what the
Russians thought of this is very good
poll data that most people after both to
early 2002 would support a political
settlement in Chechnya
and there seems to be a general
tiredness among the people for of the
war in particular the cost of their
paying and particularly when there were
conscripts young kids going down and
there were their kids going down to
fight and they're typically
ill-equipped to do this I mean this is
why you get a lot of this rating and and
these sweep operations so they can get
food right and
and things that supplies things of that
nature and so I wondered what you
thought of the Russians and just the
Russian people and having them look at
this conflict and how the human rights
group interface with them I spent the
early 2000s with the human rights groups
standing on street corners handing out
leaflets and watching them hand out the
leaflets and people would just walk by
and I wonder if that was because of
Russian and DIF kind of like American
indifference now in Afghanistan right
there's no you an outcry there's no
movement there's no pushback there's
nothing it's just happening somewhere
house and it's sufficiently distant from
Moscow that it sort of is it's somewhere
else or if that was something that the
human rights groups weren't doing right
that there was a set of strategies that
they could adopt but they weren't
getting over the wall that Putin had put
up and are not being effective and so
when we stood out there and I froze my
tail off in the deep of Moscow and Saint
Peter and winters they would hand out
broad sheets that had all the lists of
atrocities and they would light a candle
and they'd stand out there for about 90
minutes 100 minutes or so and then
they'd go home and that was the extent
of the outreach they were there to be a
symbol and I almost often wondered that
there wasn't a real lost opportunity to
engage the Russian people in terms that
they understood not a moral crusade but
the fact that this is a pragmatic thing
where blood and treasure is being spent
on your behalf and your schools not
being funded right or your 18 year old
son is going there and he does not want
to go there you don't want to go so I
often wonder like where are the Russians
in this story and how did they look at
the conflict and I'm gonna absolutely
stop right there I frankly don't really
know where to start because there I've
been trying to take notes of various
things that though if both of you said
and things that you said am i and
there's a lot of things that I would
like to do to respond to but I'm afraid
it's gonna be a little bit disjointed if
I try to do that my first of all I think
you've you've written a great book that
is really readable for I think for you
know for for anyone who has an interest
in the subject matter it's not just kind
of scholarship but very well well
written scholarship
so congratulations on that I the the the
the first point that I was going to talk
about is actually point that both of you
also made which is kind of how you write
about about genocide and whether this
was a genocide or not you stopped short
of calling it a genocide but at the same
time you kind of Lee you know you leave
the suggestion that it very well may
have been and and I of course I working
for for Human Rights Watch one of the
things that we did in the in the early
or in the late 90s and early 2000s was
actually do the documentation of the
human rights abuses that were that were
taking place and doing that work it was
never my feeling that this was a
genocide
we were not I don't think the intent to
destroy in part or in whole a particular
population was there I think what we
were looking at was a and armed forces
and police forces that were incompetent
that had gotten certain you know they
were they were they were given certain
objectives that they they had to achieve
they had no idea how to do that they
didn't have the sophisticated material
you know equipment etcetera that they
needed to be able to do that they didn't
have the kind of intellectual resources
to do it and so the the the conflict
really degenerated into something where
I think the racism that already existed
the hatred of the Chechens that already
existed I think that is really what
turned it into such an abusive conflict
but but I don't think there was an
intent to to commit genocide and I think
if you look at that the map
you put up Jason I think this it
illustrates very clearly how how in
certain parts of Chechnya there was very
you know there weren't as many abuses
the north of Jetts Nia we documented
very few abuses there were a few
disappearances a few sweep operations
but it was really mostly in that middle
stretch of of Chechnya which is well
most densely populated but which is also
kind of you know edging on the on the
mountains which is where a lot of the
rebel activity sprouted from and so I
think and then when I I've spent a lot
of time thinking about the
disappearances that were happening and
as you I mean you talk in your book
about you know three to five thousand
people who are estimated to have
disappeared and and I've spent a lot of
time thinking about you know how did
those disappearances actually happen why
did this become such a wave of
disappearances over over the course of
several years and and my sense is really
that what what happened was that once
the Russians had more or less
established kind of nominal control over
much of Chechen s territory the
insurgency was still going on in you
know all of these towns in study up the
Gihon or smart on etc all of those towns
were supposedly under Russian control
but the rebels were operating you know
pretty openly and and pretty freely and
so I think what was happening was that
the Russians would get an informant who
would give a name they would then pick
up that person they would torture that
person until that person gave up you
know gave more names then that person
would be killed would be dumped
somewhere in a forest and they would you
know that kind of they went for the the
people whose names were were mentioned
and they picked them big them up and the
same thing happened with them and so
that kind of led to this you know this
wave of disappearances but I don't think
there was necessarily you know the the
intent to kill all of these people I
mean this was part of a a very very
poorly executed military or policing
strategy in which clearly
Russian commanders did not give a hoot
about what was happening to two
junctions right I mean I think it's the
it's the the negligence on the part of
the leadership much more than that there
were specific orders to the to two
soldiers to commit these abuses so
that's the first the the second point is
about the European Court which of course
you knew I was connected and has gonna
talk about that because I was one of the
one of the people who was very much
involved in getting the getting
applications to the European Court from
from Chechen victims of abuses and you
you you you say in in the chapter on the
court that it has a controversial the
role of the court is a controversial one
and and you kinda mean you explain why
you think that it was is a controversial
one but I think that's actually a bit of
a mischaracterization of the role of the
court because the court has a particular
mandate and it is fulfilling that
mandate and that mandate is not to
conduct criminal investigations to try
people accused of war crimes or crimes
against humanity it plays you know it
plays the role of adjudicating a case
between an individual who claims their
rights have been violated and and the
country that is alleged to have
committed that violation and so I think
it's really more the the this Court
could only play this role it's the fact
that the international community didn't
step up to the plate and say what is
happening in Chechnya are war crimes and
are crimes and humanity that means that
there needs to be a response the way
there was with Ronda or with with you
miss la Via that has kind of pushed the
European Court of Human Rights into kind
of the only institution that was you
know that was hearing cases that was
looking at the you know at the evidence
and assessing the evidence so I think
the court was kind of pushed into a role
that it was never you know it was never
meant to play or maybe we or Chechen
civilians are kind of projecting what we
would like to see on a court that
doesn't have that that kind of
jurisdiction and then you talked about a
documentation center and I think if we
look at what the numbers of cases that
the European Court of Human Rights has
has looked at so far the number of
judgments we have is I think 165 right
now it's looked at hundreds of of cases
of disappearances probably approaching
about 10 you know 10% of the of the
total estimated number of people who who
have disappeared there are still
hundreds of cases pending before the the
European Court of Human Rights and so I
think if we're if we're talking about
creating the documentation were actually
you know through these court proceedings
we we have been generating an enormous
amount of evidence in some cases
evidence that very clearly pinpoints
that the people in you know run the
Russian forces in the Russian
administration who were responsible for
particular acts in a lot of cases of
course the court has documented in great
depth the the failures of the
prosecutor's office in in Russia to to
conduct real investigations into the
allegations that were put forward and so
I think you know if if we're if we're
thinking about documentation here we
have a treasure trove of good
information and also if we are you know
if we do think about the possibility who
knows one day that there could be you
know a truth commission or or or
criminal investigations into what has
happened obviously that's the first
place to to look
this is you know this is evidence that
has already been validated by by a court
of law made up of leading judges from
from all over all over Europe going back
a little bit to the role of the court
you you cite someone as talking about
how sorry I just
so one Chechen civilian has concluded in
stark terms that the roles the court is
to force the Russian government to pay a
fee for taking human life and I think I
think that what the court has done
actually goes well beyond beyond that we
went when we started okay I can I can do
this in two minutes that when in in in
19 or in 2000 when suddenly media
attention for the conflict in Chechnya
just ended right Yeltsin had resigned
the whole world knew that Putin was
going to be the next president they were
going to have to deal with this guy for
the next four years and probably much
more international you the u.s. didn't
want to engage with you know on Chechnya
any any more or at least not the way
they did in the first few weeks or
months of the conflict we we started
well what we did in in late 2000 was go
back and read interview people who we
had interviewed earlier about abuses
that had happened to them or to family
members people whose relatives had
disappeared had been executed victims of
torture to see to what extent the
Russians were actually investigating
their claims and we've been you know
documenting these claims and giving them
to the Russians they were saying we are
looking into this so we went back and we
found that none of the witnesses had
ever been questioned we found that
bodies have been you know had been
buried with all the bullets in them with
clothes on none of the you know none of
the friends except had been done at the
same time we found that that many of the
victims
had incredibly strong evidence of
wrongdoing by Russian by Russian forces
and so it felt almost criminal not to
help these people bring their cases to
the European Court of Human Rights when
we started talking to these people about
the you know about bringing cases of
course we would tell them that there you
know they could be they could receive
compensation or the court could award
moral and material damages no one was
interested in those more on material
damages everyone said no I want to bring
my case because I want recognition you
know the Russian government is denying
that anything anything happened you you
talk about the young DF case where a
Russian soldier on camera or Russian
general on camera gives an order to
execute a prisoner and the Russian
Prosecutor's Office in response to a
complaint writes to the the mother and
to memory I'll well the body is not
being found so we can't open a criminal
investigation right I mean that so the
Russians were just denying that there
was any wrongdoing in any of these cases
and what the court has what we've been
able to do through the court is actually
get recognition that yes the russian
government was responsible for these
killings for these disappearances and I
think that's a moral victory that is
really really important for for many of
of the victims that that we've
represented over the years and so it's
not just you know the money is only a
small a small part of it but I have to
say once you win the case that you know
that the applicants actually do want the
money because that most of them are
desperately poor and so if you know if
the court Awards them fifty thousand
euros that is gonna you know that's
gonna that's really gonna make an impact
on on their on their lives and often
they've lost you know they have lost
breadwinners and and so on so that I
mean certainly is a secondary issue for
most of most of the people that we
represent it but but not an unimportant
one
and well I have five minutes okay so
okay I just I might go backwards
somewhat and I'm I hope Diedrich that
that the chapter didn't come across as
unduly harsh on the European Court I I
think that wasn't my intention actually
and in many respects I used that notion
of the fee for human life because for
some people that I had talked to that
was how they equated it and it's a very
strong quote and perhaps slightly
misused in in that sense but the degree
to which I guess that I support what's
happening at the European Court of Human
Rights is I'm actually writing an
article now on the ways in which the
judgments of the court are helping us to
understand the conflict better so in
that regard I totally agree with you
about the documentation okay
the when I said you said that that the
role of the court is a controversial one
and you felt that perhaps I'd
mischaracterized that that actually
wasn't was that my role wasn't to to
mischaracterize it I think what I was
trying to say was that although these
cases are extremely important what I
found lacking was evidence that the role
of the court not only by paying
compensation but actually part of their
role is to pressure the Russian
government of the Russian judiciary to
change their practices inside Russia to
actually do something about solving the
problems themselves so they don't you
know as you know they're overloaded with
case
at the European Court of Human Rights so
I guess you know having talked to Philip
leach and Bill borrowing and people who
are actually working on that they
themselves hasn't seen any evidence that
that is really working on a significant
level so in a sense I guess my my claim
was that this has sort of been out
sourced if you like and the role of the
court it seems that they don't have the
capability to put the structure in place
to actually keep the pressure on the
Russian government so that was one of my
one of my concerns and so that that was
that I will go back now to Kim and and
Jason's sorry issues okay I have to make
the claim with regard to Kim that I
don't deal with the period of Ram zone
Kadir off I mean really my book stops in
2005 when misheard off dies so there is
a period of when you're talking about I
guess largely from 2004 to 2010 that I
don't that's not actually the period
that I deal with but that said I think
your criticism about political economy
is a is a correct one and that I
probably don't give as much traction to
that argument as I do to arguments about
racism and nationalism and so I think in
terms of understanding the conflict I
would I would absolutely agree that that
there's a shortage of that if you like
within the book itself I think that you
said that I make the claim that Russian
nationalists or Russian radical Chechen
separatists were really driven by
revenge and I don't actually make that
claim all the way throughout my book I
think that very much the character of
that resistance changes and it does fit
very much between shamil Basayev and
Aslan
yes there are the other factors at work
but these two have the main power base
within that society and so therefore I
guess that I concentrated on them I also
concentrated on them because there was a
lack of material for me about what the
other factors the other groups were
doing and I don't know if any of you
have read earlier suck Murdoch's new
book the Chechen independence movement
he was the former foreign minister it's
just come out with Palgrave and in fact
that book gives us a very nuanced
understanding of what's going on both
with shamil Basayev and what's going on
with Aslam misheard off with whom he
worked with both these men so he does
give you a sense that really up until
the death of mus hard off the struggle
was with must heart of trying to unify
sham your Messiah so there wouldn't be a
civil war with inside the church to know
it so so I think that that could have
been elaborated on if I had known more I
wish I had and so I think that's a point
very very well taken and and and I agree
the issue about the concentration of my
book being just on racism and
nationalism
I think that's slightly unfair because I
think I point out in the introduction
that this is just one aspect of this
particular war that I think has been
marginalized in our discussions and
perhaps if I talk more about political
economy I could have slightly offset
that more right to make that give the
sense that I'm only introducing one lens
through which we could try and
understand this campaign so the issue of
genocide I don't actually say that it's
genocide first art I actually make the
claim that I think by international law
that we could call this crimes against
humanity and the reason why I make that
claim is because with crimes against
humanity you can make the claim that if
there's racial prejudice that drives or
motivates people to commit particular
crimes but you don't have to prove
intent
right so and also I think that I I made
the claim very much as Didrik said right
that it is up to battalion leaders I
can't prove that there's any state
policy and I mean again if we look at
Russians during the Second World War for
example then it is very much determined
by battalion commanders who are making
decisions I can't prove I have not
absolutely no evidence to say that the
Russians are directed from the FSB or
whatever to commit crimes against
civilians so I just want it to be to be
clear about that and and hope that
that's not exactly misunderstood but I
think in a book about Chechnya you have
to address that issue precisely because
so many Chechens are convinced that
that's what has happened to them and so
I think to try and deconstruct that in a
way that's that's helpful
in terms of international law might help
us uncut some of that now sorry Jason
the the last thing was about Russians
and I think that's a really good point
right I'm prepared to accept that I
don't draw them into the discussion I
mean I think that I do draw Russian
civil society into the discussion very
much looking at Politkovskaya looking at
the role of memorial looking at the role
of the russian chechen friendship
society and and the the role of the
advocates but if you're I guess you're
asking me to do more you know survey
based work about how Russians feel about
about Chechens so and I I didn't do a
lot of that precisely time and and money
and and I think it's a it's a very
difficult thing to sort of generate real
data about I mean one can do it but you
as everybody knows with surveys you only
have a but that wasn't I mean one could
have done that but but clearly clearly I
didn't did I answer all those questions
was there some
well no I wanted to because I think that
they're all really good points and I
just wanted to make sure that you know
there was there was clarity about my you
know what I was trying to get through
and sometimes I think that it's when
someone's reading something you don't
like to be misinterpreted I guess and so
I just wanted to to make sure that that
was clear the oh I guess um one thing
that Jason brought up which I would
slightly disagree with is the fact that
when you're talking about racism that
somehow you have to prove that because
it's not a homogeneous attack on all
racial groups that it's not driven by
racism I mean you're saying that
essentially the pattern of the ways in
which the crisis occurred suggests that
okay Ernest Martin stereo Turkey there
are areas and a good rate where there
was a lot of fighting going on but I I
could never make the suggestion that
racism isn't a motivating factor
precisely because it doesn't happen
everywhere and I think that if I miss
unmei every sunder stood you know gone
because this genocide conversation is
actually very helpful because you want
to talk it's not genocide doesn't assume
that because you don't have by crimes
against humanity it racism can be one of
the factors but it's the the Genesis
behind crimes against humanity is it has
to be widespread and systematic so
that's the question I'm asking right can
could we prove that it's widespread and
systematic I see variation and could i
interject here I wonder if Emma's
talking about strategy and you're
talking about tactics or operations
well Jason might want to elaborate no
because I I mean I'm interested in Kim's
question she thinks that we're slightly
misinterpreting each other my
understanding is that Jason is talking
about underneath the windows update how
things worked when the decision was made
that war was going to be fought and what
he's saying is that in different cities
there were different levels of attacks
against civilians mhm and what you're
saying is that one of the motivating
factors that cause the word to happen at
all was a Russian hatred of Chechens no
I didn't know no I never said that that
caused the war I think you're saying
it's one of the causes and I'm not gonna
let you back down on that because all
three of us read that in your book well
no I don't think that I say I think it's
a motivating factor in the causal
origins of the war but I don't say that
it's the sole and only motive but that's
how you're presenting it though right
but then if Jason makes the claim right
that
just because it's not widespread
complete brutalization of there's no I
just want to say in here you've backed
off and we have sort of ignored the
great discussion that you have of the
aerial bombing campaigns and I think
that really helps your evidence perhaps
even more than the question of what
members of the FSB battalions do I guess
I take those for granted actually I mean
I think that I take I mean perhaps I've
I take the the disproportionality
argument for granted and I shouldn't
draw that more to the table and I think
that there are two cases of that you
know both the aerial bombing in the
first and the second war and also the
fact that and Diedrich would know it as
well absolutely no state of emergency
called absolutely no evacuation routes
set up for people to actually get out of
the country so I think I actually posed
the question in the book is this a case
of negligence right or is this you
a racial and I can't I'm not saying I
can't answer that question though
but it's a bit - you can either so I
can't say that I have heard at least
that a number of very large number of
the people that were killed in the
aerial bombing campaigns for elderly
Russians know that's the first well but
the fact that the same technique was
used in both wars indicates that the
second war can't be racist if the first
war wasn't racist ladies I would say I
guess I didn't say that the first wasn't
racist I mean I never said that either
so and I think that racism did partly
Drive the first war but I think that it
wasn't as much as the second more and I
think the precise reasons for that are
the actions of the Chechen separatists
themselves right the fact that they led
the incursion into Dagestan they there's
no evidence to suggest that they're
responsible for the apartment bombings
but the collective wisdom is right that
at least they play they may have played
some role right so also I think that the
the Russian military was extremely upset
that its so-called lost the first war
and so wanted to go back and achieve
what had set out to achieve in the
didn't achieve in in the first war so
not gone one thing I think we can do and
then you bring in some audience members
take three these keep your comments or
questions very short identify yourselves
who you are that's what
to school affiliation please realize
that a transcript is being made so that
it will be on the record and so let's
take one round and then let's bundle
some server bottle to rebuttals in okay
the department yes
so they had just a question I guess for
Jason about this workout here I'm just
getting like people with Chechnya but
it's there is some variation in terms of
this specific ethnic groups and I'm
wondering how the the ethnic groups and
maybe some of the variations in Islam
play into into that the work the theater
patterns that you see here
proper the intention property and in
terms of where the sweets were right
okay so lots in dark Ethan - and let's
go in order yeah I mean I can answer
Jack's second question about the
strategic and tactical lessons I think
in the case of the first war that the
evidence suggests that they sent in you
know eighteen and nineteen year old
foot soldiers who'd actually been had
never trained together in some instances
and were sent into the capital and had
no idea you know what they were doing
and plus they were fighting against
Chechens who were very aware of what the
the physical terrain was both in the
mountains and within Grozny itself so
what they did learn was that they had to
privately contract soldiers with a great
deal more experience and that they would
use the the common soldier right in the
in the cases of the sweeps they would
use the common soldier to surround the
village and then the privately
contracted soldier would do the harsher
more brutal work if you like so in that
respect they did learn a big lesson and
that they they knew that they had to
work in smaller tactical very very
strong units the other thing that was
different was that they stopped they
they bombed their area for about three
months which they did similarly in the
first war but essentially what they did
was that they prohibited ground troops
from going in too quickly so the
consensus is that the bombing during the
second war was far more widespread and
far more damaging that it had been in
the first war so their their operational
tactic was to save their own men and
then to use these stronger units and the
question of whether they've won or not
it depends on where you're what
perspective you're coming from whether
you're coming from a moral perspective
whether you're coming from a political
perspective and
so they've managed to quiet in the
situation for the time being I mean I'm
not sure as illiac Martov has just
recently said in his book that you know
this is not going to change the
situation once Chechens have it that the
opportunity to rest they're going to
rise up again I'm not exactly sure about
that actually I think that there's
there's a sort of idealism in in that
itself but Ramzan Kadyrov is not the
answer for them I want to started to
talk about a Jackson eiders question
about I'm not going to answer the first
one exactly on the military operational
lessons that were learned but about what
they have done now and what they how
you'd make the argument that it hasn't
served their interests
I think the key change between the two
wars was the decision to move over to
Chechen ization and to give essentially
control over the territory to Ramzan
Kadyrov and his forces and I'm going to
take Jason on very strongly on this I
think that Putin has lost control I
think it was a gradual process that
started in 2004 2005 and by 2009 2010
Ramzan Kadyrov US forces had operational
control over all of the security
operations that were happening on the
territory there were still Russian
forces that were left on the ground but
they were only leaving their barracks
when they were ordered to because of
Ramzan Kadyrov's orders that came
through the operational mechanisms there
was no longer anybody in the federal
level FSB or MVD the internal security
forces that had operational mandate over
what Ramzan Kadyrov was doing he doesn't
have any power outside of Chechnya and
they demonstrated that by foiling one of
an apparent assassination attempt
against one of his rivals in Moscow but
inside Chechnya there's nobody who can
touch him and one of the things that
happened just this past year that makes
that even clearer is that ROM son was
given control over an international
airport that opened up again in Chechnya
for the first time since the fighting
had started there are still a few
Russian FSB officers who check passports
there but it's a few ethnic
in this huge sea of heavily armed very
corrupt Chechen militants who are you
know holding up millions of dollars to
pay them off and also the threat of
having an accident happened on their way
back to Russia if they don't go along
with what the forces want and so
essentially the airport has men that
Ramzan can look elsewhere for other
patrons outside of Moscow and the work
that I do in the book demonstrates that
that's a common pattern among warlords
they look for alternatives and Ramzan
has every incentive and every mechanism
to look for alternatives and so the best
argument I think you can make to the
Russians about what they did wrong is
you lost control over a piece of your
territory you're absolutely right you
didn't end terrorism by doing that dumb
and Jetta boat was just the latest one
it may not be as many suicide bombing
says what's happening in 2001 but it's
been going up the last couple of years
in terms of a number of victims and in
terms of the number of terrorist attacks
that is happening that's been very well
documented by CSIS and Sarah
Mendelssohn's work I think if the
Russians at all decided that they wanted
to go in they can just go in and do what
well and get rid of Ramzan could do and
I don't know that what cleansing with
well I don't think that it's simple that
they've lost control they have to go in
with a major military intervention and
they would have to fight lumps on Kadir
of such they're quite capable of doing
it they will do if they feel as though
they're losing the region they've
already done it before it doesn't matter
whether it's a salon must harder for
weather
I had I think the other thing they did
was we haven't talked to us it's clamp
down on media readiness is not a person
like the first touch of the world over
some journals could be on the
battlefield this is much more
information blockade no surprise no give
a lot more information I think we would
add that bucket been that effective but
they still nonetheless tried to clamp
down on being shown at home very kind of
universe at the beginning magician
ization I think is critical or they
weren't great with a thing you do not
want to be doing the sweeps in fact in
these data you can see right around 2004
the Chechen starving or abusing the
Russians do they definitely handing it
off as something we're seeing for
example in Iraq or somebody it's a
common kind of strategy if stuff out of
the box the contracts holders I think
we're also very good we mentioned the
contract so in the file
this is a very different world as work
one because the Chechens go first and in
this case the Russians had more of an
excuse to enter
well that's because this gives the
Russians ability to I don't want to
doing very quickly I don't want to do in
camouflage because like frankly none of
us really know and some of these things
but Ron time can be incredibly strong
let's try it out of 10 years we could go
tomorrow dangerous that could you could
go to Mars we don't actually know my
sense though is that he has a every
incentive to play out of strongest I
think that be careful I just don't I
think the Russians have more leaders
then he doesn't know he's got the air at
work out what the Russians are pumping
tons of money through I'd say the
financial would like all that corruption
all that and then what would happen if
they shut off the money pull down Robin
and then what happens and they favor
civil war but that doesn't mean
necessarily he doesn't control them
right right so he'd be good just show
this figure it off that's one way of
doing it they could that you just
haven't defined a rule strategy with a
chance of finding ourselves we put the
walls up caninus right about the
judgments by trying to Tina spill over I
think
until rung start cooperating with one of
the enemies or runs on gets bumped off
well I mean I'll contribute to this
discussion about crumbs on and whether
Russia has has won or lost this war and
I think it depends very much on how you
define winning or losing right I mean
the way you're putting it yes maybe they
they have won but I and I think that
Ramzan has control far beyond actually I
mean you were you were saying that he
doesn't have control in Moscow but at
the same time he has been assassinating
people in in Moscow he's assassinated
people and in the Gulf
he's we have the case in in Austria we
know that in Austria in Norway and other
places the the Chechen diaspora is is
frightened is feely frightened because
Ramzan has his informers everywhere and
it goes where you know it goes well
beyond just the Moscow Dion diaspora
it's it's all over the place and I mean
if you look at that look back at August
1996 the Russians had also set up this
kind of loyalist Chechen police and the
moment they saw that the you know the
winds were changing they switched sides
and suddenly I mean the loyalties of
these you know the people that Ramzan
has has surrounded himself with both
terms on himself are very tenable and
then to the you know the kind of
pro-russian cause is very tenable
that can change at any moment and the
whole you know you're back to a
completely different situation than you
then you have right now so I think it
continues to be really volatile and I
mean if if winning is creating a kind of
more you know a stable Society obviously
Russia has has totally failed at doing
that in pursuing its own political
interests you know I'm not so sure that
they are really all that comfortable
with what is going on right now I wanted
to go back to one one thing you said
Emma this is not related to you that the
questions but about the European Court
and how it had not been able to change
practices inside Russia I want to make
two points about that one is of course
we don't know to what extent it has
changed practices because if the you
know if fewer abuses are taking place is
that because there's more scrutiny from
the European Court etcetera or is that
because there or would that have
happened without the European Court I
mean it's one of these things that we
just you know we cannot really know in
terms of changing and where we do know
that there has not been a change is in
how Russian Russian prosecutors are
investigating allegations of abuses
we've not seen any real change in in how
that happens no matter no matter that
the European Court in every single
judgment it has issued has been scathing
about the way Russia has conducted its
investigations but the court has a
judicial function it is it is the
committee of ministers of the Council of
Europe that has the political function
of making sure that judgments are
actually implemented and so there were
actually back at the earlier chapters in
in your book talking about the lack of
political will to really deal with what
is going on in in in in Russia and in
Chechnya and so it really you know the
the court can only issue these judgments
it can mandate certain changes to
legislation for example but when it
comes to kind of established practices
in the prosecutor's office or in the
military
it requires political will on the part
of the Russian government to make those
changes and I mean we all know that that
is not going to come just like that so
that's going to require that the Council
of Europe you know the political arms of
the Council of Europe actually putting
the pressure on Russia to to make that
happen and that that is not that has not
been happening
what
in terms of you know countries having to
prove themselves by so fast accumulation
of wealth in Russian that compensation
that heat up Conn said in fact that the
Soviet Union wasn't exactly a financial
success you know and then you look at
the Chechens insurance pipes between
themselves as being a movement that is
capable of war or or has the right to be
you know a real nation on nations
forgiveness if there's if there are NGOs
whatever service intermediaries I can
see that playing off one against another
trying to find you know of human
solutions in terms of you know people
trying to help each other like I said
that will be support again financial
that'd be posting it too strongly but
you know having intermediary disease
there you know this more in terms of
caring you know caregivers right so what
are the conditions in the NGO okay good
so let's see if it sparks an even more
debate I think among our blackness I'll
ask everyone to responses to two minutes
just with regard to the contract
soldiers as far as I know that they're
they're Russian nationals I have no
evidence otherwise to suggest that there
are any foreign fighters so I don't
think could Europe's got quite the same
currency as Gaddafi so as far as I know
yeah with regard to your your question
and thank you for that I think that
Diedrichs point about the testimonies or
the the judgments coming out of European
Court of Human Rights is a very valid
one and I think that's that's a place
that we should continue looking at but
for me that doesn't really go to the
heart of what I think is is problematic
here and I must say that for me
personally that I like the idea of
public hearings and public hearings as a
venue where in this case I don't think
it would take place in Chechnya but I
think it could take place for example
amongst the Chechen diaspora living in
Austria which there are 16,000 that
we're currently trying to work with to
to set up panels where you do have
people being able to talk about what
took place and to have transcripts made
and to have discussion generated so
sorry
I guess I guess you've got to ask the
question of who is the panel for and
from my point of view the panel's not
really for us the panel is for people
who have been victimized and for them to
have the opportunity to you know as
Didrik said to gain recognition but also
to gain recognition within their
community about what's about what's
taken place and if you aren't if you're
a victim of a historical crime and
you're not going to get recognition
within the normal avenues of justice
then I really think that you know it's
it's not enough to just do documentation
and research you know I think that these
issues need we need to think about ways
in which we can bring people together
that aren't about truth and
reconciliation commissions and such or
or as international criminal tribunals
but but where people get the opportunity
to be heard because we're always going
to have asymmetrical Wars where these
things aren't going to happen so one of
the about the idea of hearings one of
the things that the European Court does
not do is grant a role for applicants so
the victims don't actually play really
any role in the proceedings we interview
them we make you know we base our applet
the application on what the person has
told us we kind of verify the evidence
they present etc but they are never
called to the court to actually testify
about what happened to them even in the
rare cases where the court does schedule
a kind of a public hearing in one of
these cases it's actually the
representatives of the applicant who
speak and so in the one case in which we
had a hearing of the mother of India who
described in the in your book she came
to Strasbourg but she was never able to
actually speak
self and so clearly if if we're looking
at I mean obviously the recognition is
really important but if we're looking at
people actually being able to speak
their mind to talk about what happened
to them to offload a lot of that
emotional baggage that is not happening
at Apple at the moment in terms of the
kind of efforts to bring people together
to bridge the the differences of course
they have been there have been groups
that have been working on kind of
peacebuilding
on bringing Russians and Chechens
together and have them you know have
them experience things together do fun
stuff together bringing children Russian
and Chechen children together the
problem is that you're really I mean
these efforts are fighting against a
media apparatus that is feeding hatred
to to the Russian population about
Chechens I mean I I have good friends in
Russia who when I tell them about the
work I've been doing and about people
who've disappeared you know they are
convinced that these people must have
done something wrong and even when I
tell them you know then at least they
should have you know criminal
proceedings they you know they don't
they don't buy that and so you're
fighting against a tide that is so much
more powerful than a few NGOs can do to
kind of bring people together and and
help bridge these you know kind of
misunderstandings that that exist on
both sides let's say you know it's a
very very difficult undertaking yeah
Anna's question I think there's very
little that the United States as an
actor can do because the reset it's just
sort of working we need Russia in North
Korea Iran for liberation reasons we
need their cooperation in Afghanistan so
there's not going to be a lot of
government attention to and that's why
the ECHR is so unique because it's a
state-based agency that nonetheless can
have an impact on things but it's not
clear how much power states have any way
to get change inside other states and so
I think the answer to your question is
publicity and Emma Gilligan's book helps
a lot in bringing people
to these issues and I think an upcoming
event that has an opportunity to bring
publicity is the Olympics in Sochi
I think that that is something that I
would guess human rights advocates are
going to rally around to bring attention
to what's happening in these work
wonderfully and a lot of comparative
cases where they do or create new forms
of violence and if we are very careful
we might just actually kick over another
sound round of score settling and
disputes and things like that's over
before we did anything every need -
hypothetically speaking because I don't
think the Russians are gonna do this
himself I would certainly want to know
what the Chechens themselves thought
both the wisdom of actually doing a
score settling or or war crimes tribunal
but morally I mean I agree I mean we
push you pretty hard on on whether these
are crimes against humanity but I mean
the amount of violence this visit on the
Chechen population is staggering and I
think the book it does a fantastic job
in at least bringing that to light - so
I agree with Kevin you've gots a great
way to end just a couple of
announcements before we thank our
panelists first talking of large scale
violence and what I said that World War
two
they're really going inside and well
that's gonna happen right across the
hallway in a little bit so if you want
to be cheered up even more you can go
there second announcement Wednesday new
next event in the series 12:19 new the
130 benefit roba post market marble
because n even work on human rights
networks in East Europe and her policy
making discussion will be Lennie
Bernardo of the open societies is the
best to be a good master so please join
us with this Friday at noon on Wednesday
the panel